good morning Maureen and John and
nerdfighters today we're gonna talk
about something that pisses me off at
the end of last year there was a battle
in the UK the kid who won the X Factor
Joe Mekel Derry who I know nothing about
was apparently a shoo-in for the highest
selling artist in the UK Christmas
charts that is until Rage Against the
Machine decided to Rage Against the
Machine and get a profanity-laden song
from 1992 to the top of the UK charts
and they did it using an online
anti-establishment social media thing
Rage Against the Machine beat Joe
McElderry by like 50,000 units proving
to the world that we're not just sheep
and a capitalist na na ki except it
turns out that we were raging against
the wrong machine because Joe Michael
dairies music is owned by the same
people as rage against the machines
music Sony Music owns both Sony BMG
which is Joe's label and Epic Records
which is rage against the machines label
so while the anti-establishment folk
we're fighting their battles Sony was
laughing all the way to the bank and
that is what I want to talk about today
brands and their hypocrisy big
corporations create these things called
brands so that they can sell more stuff
to more people they can use these brands
to create specific marketing campaigns
to hit specific demographics of people
who believe specific things all the
while those big companies don't give a
crap about those brand values as long as
the brand's continue to make money don't
believe me so Dove soap and skin care
those people you know those people they
have this great marketing campaign about
how real women are beautiful and that's
so great and then you have a company
like Axe body spray and Axe body spray
is like Shh I'll spray myself and then I
can use women for sex and I'm sure you
know where I'm going with this axe and
Dove are both owned by Unilever things
get even crazier with media companies
because they own like 10,000 different
properties for example the company that
owns the UK softcore porn magazine nuts
also owns the hanna-barbera cartoon
franchise that company being Time Warner
MTV has a similar structure earning both
television channels for young children
and
horny men I was personally extremely
disappointed to find out that the
National Geographic Channel is owned by
the same people who run fox freaking
news over here you're talking about the
beauty and wonder of natural and
cultural diversity and the power of
science and over here your Fox News and
food companies are no better Kraft is
busy boasting the importance of meatless
meals with their Boca burger franchise
while simultaneously shilling both hot
dogs and steak sauce to quote satisfy
your primal urges Kraft until recently
was actually owned by Philip Morris the
people who make Marlboro cigarettes
which was possibly the most intense
brand hypocrisy of all time with Kraft
focusing on family meals and Philip
Morris focusing on killing people and
Unilever going back to the beginning is
doing it again with their food brands
here offering up slimfast with keys to
your weight loss success while pimping
like 12 different ice cream companies
including Breyers Klondike bar Good
Humor and Ben & Jerry's and speaking of
Ben and Jerry's are they supposed to be
like the quirky cute independent ice
cream company for the independent
thinking Jerry Garcia loving kind of
hippie person and now I find out that
they're owned by like one of the biggest
food companies in the world that's just
depressing live folks there is only one
corporate philosophy only one set of
brand values make more money if this
means spending money to do good things
so that more people will buy our stuff
then they will do that but these big
corporations do not have a conscience
they have one goal one goal only and
sometimes it's easy to forget that but
it will always be true Maureen I will
see you on Wednesday